this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video we're
going to talk all about nad plus
metabolism
how nad plus is generated within cells
how nad plus is consumed
and how nad plus is important to a
variety of different cellular processes
within a cell
and how the decline in nadplus during
aging can be linked to the different
hallmarks of aging
and then lastly we'll look at different
ways of being able to rejuvenate the
levels of nad plus
either through supplementation through
inhibiting enzymes like the grade nad
plus
or by activating enzymes that help to
generate nad plus within a cell
and evaluate whether at further
questions and what clinical trials are
currently in progress
so the best place to start is with nad
itself so nad stands for nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide
and this is one of the most abundant
molecules in the human body
it is important not only as a coenzyme
for different redox reactions
and for energy metabolism but also as an
essential co-factor for different
enzymes
notably the sertoin family and poly adp
ribose polymerases known as pops that
are important in dna repair
but it is thought that there are more
than 300 enzymes relying on nadplus for
their activity
so i think we can say that nad plus is
pretty important
however nad plus levels have been shown
to decline as we age
when there's high amounts of dna damage
which is partly due to the activation
of these parp enzymes and due to certain
activity
and also during alcohol metabolism and
so for these different reasons there's a
lot of interest at the moment in trying
to restore nad plus levels
to alleviate some of the symptoms
associated with nad plus decline
but before we go into some of these
methods we really need to understand
energy metabolism and how it works
otherwise what i say could just sound
like a load of gibberish
so in my opinion the best way to
understand it is to understand why
nadplus is
called nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotides
and that can be seen by looking at its
structure where i've indicated
different groups of the compounds and
where the name comes from
so the first part nicotinamide comes
from the fact that it has this
nicotinamide
group attached to a rye based molecule
the second ribose molecule in nad plus
is attached to an adenosine group
hence the nicotinamide adenine aspects
of the name
and then the last part dinucleotide
refers to the fact that these two ribose
molecules
are attached through two phosphates and
this is similar to the backbone of
nucleic acids and so each nucleic acid
is otherwise referred to
as a nucleotide until you've got a
dinucleotide present
and so the reason i went to so much
detail here isn't because i love
biochemistry
which i obviously do but because it
helps us to understand
how nad plus is generated and then
consumed within a cell
and so it's thought that there are three
different pathways within a cell that
can generate nad plus and these three
pathways are nicely summarized in this
figure from a recent review article
on nad plus metabolism which was a good
source of information for this video
and so on the far left you can see that
there's the dnova pathway to nad plus
formation that starts from tryptophan
tryptophan being an amino acid as you
can see there's quite a few steps that
take tryptophan through to nat plus
and for these reasons some of the
enzymes involved in these steps aren't
expressed in all cell types and so we
saw that this dnava pathway is mainly
occurring only in the liver
the second pathway to nadplus is from
vitamin precursors known as nicotinic
acid or you might know it as niacin
and this gets converted to nadplus
feared the prius handler pathway
and the last method is the so-called
salvage pathway
which generates nad plus from
nicotinamide nam
so if we go back to the biochemical
structure of nad plus that i showed you
earlier
nicotinamide is just this moiety creep
at the end thus i've indicated
and the reason it's called the salvage
pathway is because when nad plus
is consumed by different enzymes within
the body such as serotonins and pops
one of the products is nicotinamide and
so nicotinamide can be converted back
into nad plus
and therefore effectively rescue the nad
plus levels
the way it's converted back is by going
through an intermediate known as nmn
nicotinamides mononucleotides so let's
take a look at that structure
so as before nicotinamide refers to the
fact that
nmn contains the nicotinamide group and
then this time is
known as a mononucleotide because unlike
nad plus which is a dinucleotide
nmn has one ribose and one phosphate and
our understanding of the salvage pathway
was further added to
in 2004 when charles brenner discovers
nicotinamide ribosides
which can be converted into nmn and
element as i just said can be converted
into nad plus
and this becomes clearer when we look at
the structures again so
nr nicotinamide riboside has just
nicotinamides and ribose
and so to get from nr to nmn it needs to
be phosphorylated
and so there are kinases that have been
identified that have shown that
nr can be converted into nmn now i feel
like i've gone into quite a bit of
detail here to really explain to you how
nad plus can be generated within a cell
but the reason i have is because we'll
come back to it later when we try to
discuss different methods and approaches
to rejuvenating nad plus levels
but firstly we need to understand why do
nad plus levels decline
well i've already mentioned two nad plus
consuming
enzymes so two and pops but nad plus can
also be consumed by two enzymes
cd38 and cd157 and you can see it very
clearly in this figure that these
enzymes are found at the cellular
membrane
and they're called ectoenzymes because
they have activity
outside of the cell and so whilst nad
consumption may seem like a bad thing
because you're decreasing nat plus
levels
these different types of enzymes require
nat plus to carry out their function
so in the case of sartoons their
function is to deactivate different
proteins
that is important for activating
different stress resistance pathways
within a cell such as autophagy
as with the pups they use nadplus to
drive reactions that can help prepare
dna damage
again something that's pretty important
however the function of cd 38
and well even more so cd157 are not
currently characterized as well
however what seems to be the case is
that both cd38
and cd157 are upregulated in aging
tissues
and as i mentioned in a previous video
it seems that upregulation of cd38
is a major culprit for the decline in
nad plus levels that occurs during aging
and the interesting thing with this
study was the increase in expression of
cd38
in this case on macrophages a form of
immune cells
seem to be occurring due to the
secretion of inflammatory factors
by senescent cells in the neighboring
physical fat and liver
and so it seems like energy plus decline
could be linking the different hallmarks
of aging together
and well we'd probably be here all day
and longer if i went through all of the
studies that have shown links between
nad plus metabolism and the different
hallmarks of aging
but just to show a few nad plus decline
has been associated with metabolic
dysfunction
and in a mouse model whereby they
inhibited cd38
this enzyme i just told you about that
consumes nadplus
they found that the mice were protected
from obesity have increased metabolic
rates and have
relatively normal glucose metabolism
during high fat diets
and during aging moreover cd38
expression
increases in the course of alzheimer's
disease progression
and the alzheimer's disease mouse model
lacking cd38
resulted in elevated nad plus levels in
their brains
and they also showed a milder disease
phenotype
and so whilst i've specifically included
two examples that include cd38
cd38 is emerging as a key enzyme
involved in inflammation
antenescence which could be also helping
to link nadplus
metabolism and its decline all of the
different hallmarks of agent
in particular because we know that there
are senescent cells in the brain and
that in itself has been linked to
alzheimer's disease so it's all a matter
of trying to put the puzzle pieces
together
but the more important question is if we
know that this is the case and nad plus
is really important
what strategies are there to increase
nad plus levels
well if we consider the analogy whereby
water
is an 80 plus then there are three main
ways in which you can maintain
the water levels in a sink firstly is to
prevent any leakages
and loss of water in this case
representing the different enzymes that
consume nad plus
for example cd38 then there's the fact
that you want to increase the supply of
water
that can come from precursors to nad
plus
and then the third strategy is to open
up the forceps to allow the flow of
water
to be stronger and this could come by
activating different enzymes involved in
the metabolism
and generation of nad plus or as i like
to think of it
the make break or take strategies to
prevent nad plus decline
so let's start with the taking
strategies ways of supplementing nad
plus levels
since that's why we have a majority of
information at the moment
one option would be to supplement with
nicotinamide
since it can be converted back to nad
plus by the salvage pathway
however at the moment the consensus
seems to be that at high levels
nicotinamide seems to be acting as a
feedback inhibitor
of nad plus dependent enzymes including
parps and sertoins
an alternative idea is to use niacin
which is actually
already commonly found in multivitamins
however there seems to be some concerns
with niacin in terms of high doses
in particular because it can cause
flushing of the skin
so instead nmn and nr have also been
investigated
in their ability to increase nad plus
levels in addition to the many promising
results from pre-clinical studies and
different muscle organisms
using nmn and nr as you can see here in
screenshots taken from this review
article
nmn nr administration seems to be safe
and can efficiently increase
nad plus levels and healthy volunteers
there have been more phase one clinical
trials using nr as opposed to any men
but at the moment there are trials being
conducted using both
precursors separately i should add i'm
looking at different aspects
for example i've highlighted one of the
nicotinamide riboside trials
where they are planning to assess the
cognitive performance in
patients with mild cognitive impairment
and so data from that will be
particularly interesting
however what would be most interesting
is one to get
long-term safety trials to see the
impacts of taking these dietary
supplements
along with the proper dose treatment
periods and consideration of the
diversity of participants
as this will better help with
translation of these therapies
now what's commonly asked is what's
better to take
nmn or nr and at the moment without any
direct comparisons
it is pretty much impossible to say but
there's a couple of interesting points
that are worth mentioning
the first one revolves around
bioavailability and the second one
revolves around metabolism
now if we draw a big box around the
dietary supplementation of nmn or nr
and the outcomes that we see in these
other clinical studies or in mouse
models
at the moment we can probably just put
in a big fat question mark
because it is still being investigated
however due to advances in being able to
track
nad precursors by using isotopic labels
what is known as that intraphenous
administration of
nr or nmn delivers intact molecules to
multiple tissues
however if it's taken orally they seem
to be metabolized to nicotinamide in the
liver
moreover in this 2016 study they showed
that when nicotinamide riboside was
taken by human patients
it increased the levels of naad which is
one of the components of the prius
handler pathway
whereby you generate nad plus from
niacin and so that doesn't quite make
sense given that this is a different
pathway to the one in which
nr contributes to and so a recent
preprint has come out that has tried to
address why this might be the case
and it seems like the situation is just
even more complicated
because now it seems that the gut
microbiome is also playing a role
and can metabolize nmn into nicotinamide
so the plot just thickens and this could
be thickened even further if i told you
that all of our gut microbiomes do
differ in different ways
and therefore how different people
respond to the supplementation of
nr or nmn could very much differ i'd say
basically there's a lot of investigation
still to be done but hopefully some of
these clinical trials will provide
a bit more information and it's also
worth pointing out that
along with nr and nmn there's the
recently identified nrh
a reduced form of nr and this appears to
be more stable and more potent
in terms of increasing nad plus levels
and has been described by charles
brenner as an interesting molecule
however it's very scarce in terms of any
data at the moment
but i'll be sure to keep you updated
when i find out more but this is not the
only strategy
a more recent area of development are
targeting nad plus degrading enzymes
such as cd38 and cd157 and so i
mentioned earlier some of the benefits
in terms of the mouse models when either
cd38 was inhibited
or the gene encoding cd38 was knocked
out
and so several inhibitors of cd38 either
already exist or are in development
one that already exists is apigenin
which is a naturally occurring flavonoid
that enhances nad plus levels in human
cells and mouse liver tissue
and has been shown to improve glucose
and lipid homeostasis
in mouse models of obesity another
flavonoid is luteolinidine
that again shows activity as a cd38
inhibitor
however both of these are very much
under investigated at the moment
and are not as advanced in our knowledge
as nad precursors
and then the last strategy is to
increase nad plus production by
activating the enzymes involved in its
biosynthesis
one of these enzymes is nampt which is
converting
nicotinamide into nmn i've highlighted
two compounds that i thought are able to
activate this enzyme in this table here
however it's important to point out that
again the research in this area is still
pretty young
and it's not necessarily clear if these
molecules have off-target effects and
are also
influencing other pathways within a cell
and so all in all there's a lot of open
questions
firstly whether or not there are any
long-term consequences
to boosting nad plus levels whether any
of these supplements have
specificity for different tissues in
particular due to the fact that the
degradation of nmn and nr now seems to
be very complicated
and then looking more specifically at
what is the most effective
therapeutic dose and could they be used
for different
age-associated diseases then there's the
idea of whether or not they could be
used in combination or whether these
approaches to inhibit nad plus consuming
enzymes are gonna be more superior
again it's just too early to know and
then the other thing that i always find
fascinating is the fact that nadplus
levels
fluctuate during the day because it is
under regulation
as well as influencing the circadian
rhythm and so
understanding the chrono
pharmacodynamics and kinetics of these
different
strategies is also something that i
would find interesting because maybe
there are certain times a day that are
more effective than others
but all in all it seems very promising
so with that i would like to say thank
you to this video sponsor longevity
technology for which i'm very grateful
longevity technology deliver high
quality daily news and insights in
research
investments and technologies that extend
health span and lifespan
find the link to their website in the
description so i hope you've learned
something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
with that thanks for listening